[Musique]
bonjour merci dimanche en politique
merci d'être avec nous une fois par mois
on sortira de nos plateaux pour parler
plus librement des sujets qui font débat
et pour commencer avec un clin d'oeil
nous sommes à l'édito à dijon pour un
sujet qui a beaucoup exciter les
éditorialistes les rythmes scolaires
trois réformes en dix ans la france ne
trouve pas le bon rythme
après la réforme très controversée
voulue par françois hollande des quatre
jours et demi emmanuel macron a
entrouvert la porte dans laquelle se
sont engouffrés un tiers des écoles
françaises revenu à quatre jours élus
parents enseignants tous ont un avis ils
sont autour de ces tables et ils vont
nous le donner dans ce dossier il ya les
maires d'abord trois maires trois
situations différentes bonjour thierry
falconnet maire ps de chenôve en côte
d'or 14 mille habitants dominique
derrien mary dei de saint sauveur en
puisaye dans l'yonne 900 habitants c'est
ça à peu près et didier migaud maire de
brétigny c'est à peu près la même taille
en côte d'or bonjour à la vie mais bon
jour il ya aussi les parents isabelle
amis vous êtes membre de la fcpe
fédération de parents d'élèves ils
avaient le râteau vous êtes maman
d'élève at-elle c'est en côte d'or vous
vouliez revenir à quatre jours et puis
il y a les enseignants olga jack bonjour
vous êtes une des secrétaires du snui pp
le syndicat majoritaire
rajoutons que cette émission vous pouvez
la suivre aussi sur la page facebook de
françois bourgogne réagir poser des
questions on en fera part et on en
parlera avec nos invités
vous prendrez bien tous vos micros
lorsque je vous parlerai de le dire
aussi la dernière en forme réforme en
date c'était les quatre jours et demi il
y avait avec le mercredi matin d'école
il y avait une volonté derrière ça
égalisé les chances plus de temps
scolaire plus de loisirs plus d'éveil
jerry falconnet je commence par vous
c'était une
bonne idée c'était une fausse bonne idée
vu le tumulte que ça a créé c'était une
très bonne idée
c'était une très bonne idée qu'il
fallait mettre en oeuvre dans nos
communes
donc ça a demandé la mobilisation de
tous de tous les acteurs parce que je
pense que cette réforme si on voulait
qu'elle réussisse il faut avec tous les
acteurs de l'école soit impliqué d'abord
les les parents les collectivités mais
aussi les services de l'éducation
nationale
le tissu associatif local les services
municipaux donc nous on a effectivement
mobiliser tout le monde autour d'eux une
bonne idée pour vous une idée pour vous
alors moi je me tends vers didier
maingot maire rural
je vous vois rigoler donc fausse bonne
idée pour vous oui plutôt fausse bonne
idée alors il n'y a pas de fausse bonne
idée en fait par principe toutes les
idées sont bonnes à prendre
par contre ce qui est sûr c'est que dans
la mise en oeuvre de cette idée un
manque flagrant de préparation et puis
des communes notamment peu plus petit
rural livrée à elle-même pour mettre en
oeuvre quelque chose très vite sans
aucune préparation
dominique vais rien on a beaucoup parlé
de la différence monde urbain monde
rural dans les dernières échéances
politiques
est-ce que là dedans l'a senti est ce
que finalement c'était peut-être bonne
idée pour l'urbain fausse bonne idée
pour le rural ou alors il y avait
effectivement une différence entre
l'urbain et le rural liées notamment au
regroupement scolaire et aux transports
dans ces cas là on peut pas gérer de la
même façon des activités périscolaires
avec un groupe scolaire regroupant
toutes les classes et avec des classes
un petit peu éclatée donc il ya eu ce
souci là mais j'ai une commune qui est à
cheval en fête entre les deux entre
l'urbain et le bras même si elle est
petite même s'ils connaissent même si
elle est totalement au milieu du rural
nous n'avons pas de transforce de
transport nous avons une école qui va
bien de la maternelle jusqu'à la
troisième et j'ai cru que c'était une
bonne idée
et pourtant bien qu ayant la possibilité
de travailler avec tout le monde et de
ceux de la mettre en oeuvre sans avoir
le souci
des petites communes rurales pouvait
avoir ce sont des parents et des
enseignants qui m'ont demandé de
l'arrêter du coup j'en ai déduit que
c'était peut-être même si j'ai cru que
ça pouvait être une bonne idée c'était
peut-être une fausse bonne idée
alors on a des élus et isabelle amis
vous représentez la fcpe ici les parents
d'élèves cette principale fédération de
parents d'élèves
là on n'a pas parlé des enfants
finalement dans ce qu'on vient de dire
alors on va y venir un bien sûr mais si
on se souvient cette réforme au départ
elle est là pour les enfants au départ
et en particulier les enfants les plus
en difficulté vous c'est pour cette
raison-là que la fcpe elle est très
dubitatifs sur le fait de revenir très
vite en arrière sur cette réforme
elle n'est pas lé pa dubitative elle est
convaincue que c'est une très mauvaise
idée que de revenir en arrière
l'intérêt des quatre jours et demi c'est
s'adapter au rythme de l'enfant c'était
de parler de l'enfance était de mettre
l'enfant au centre des préoccupations
donc c'est que c'est compliqué pour
certaines communes vous l'avez dit
maintenant c'est pas parce que c'est
compliqué c'est pas absolument
nécessaire on a eu en 2008 une
catastrophe on est passé on a passé la
semaine de quatre jours c'est à dire on
a compressé en quatre jours
quand vous voyez que les enfants
français s'ils sont à quatre jours
d'école ils font à 140
ils doivent faire en 144 jours ce que
font leurs camarades en europe sur 182
jours
voilà c'est tout donc ce qu'on nous a
quatre jours pour les là pour vous ça
marchait mais je veux on creuse les
inégalités claire et isabelle râteau
vous vous êtes maman d'élève et et quand
on a préparé l'émission vous m'avez dit
moi je veux venir pour les enfants juste
mal à vous que votre position vous êtes
vous
parle des enfants mais vous avez une
position diamétralement opposées oui
c'est tellement parce que moi je pense à
l'enfant qui doit se lever mercredi
matin et sur cinq jours c'est difficile
avant il soulevait le samedi matin oui
il y avait un jour au milieu qui était
le mercredi ne suis pas totalement
opposé aux quatre jours et demi mais je
suis opposé aux quatre jours et demi sur
cinq jours d'affilée c'est trop dur pour
eux c'est tous les soirs des devoirs
parce que ça aussi il faut y penser
lisons pas un soir où ils peuvent se
poser on se reposer et bien souvent plus
les activités basse et le mercredi donc
bah on est obligé de faire la croix sur
certaines activités parce que les
enfants ne peuvent pas tout assumer
avant de passer aux autres je vous
redonne la parole parce que vous je vous
voyais rire sur le tous les soirs des
devoirs tous les soirs des devoirs à
partir du moment où l'on considère qu'il
n'y a pas de devoirs à la maison
il ne devrait pas y avoir de devoirs à
la voilà cardiaque juste après voici
enfin des enseignants forcément mais moi
j'ai envie de vous dire une chose
imaginons vous soyez les par les heureux
parents d'une famille de cinq enfants
dont cinq enfants y en a quatre qui vont
bien il y en a qui va mal pour qui
l'école c'est compliqué qui est en
difficulté on vous dit il ya un levier
qui permet ça va pas tout solutionner ça
va pas tout résoudre mais il ya le geek
vous permet de faire en sorte que cet
enfant là il a eu mieux ce le vieil
c'est de respecter son rythme c'est de
s'adapter vraiment à ses besoins ça va
vous demander des efforts d'organisation
ça va demander à toute la famille voilà
de se poser et de réfléchir et de mettre
en oeuvre un certain nombre de choses ça
va coûter de l'argent
est-ce que vous abandonnez cet enfant au
prétexte que ça va être compliqué est ce
que vous faites ce choix d'abandonner
l'enfant
on a on à 20% d'enfants qui ont besoin
qu'on s'accorde à leur rythme
alors c'est 20% d'enfants on ne peut pas
les abandonner la position de votre
syndicat là dessus c'est quoi
c'était bien c'était pas bien vous êtes
sensible à quoi les enfants étaient
fatigués ou il ya un enfant sur cinq
qu'il faut pas abandonner
on est sensible à tous je crois que je
crois qu'ils n'ont mais je vais
développer un petit je crois que je
crois que les enseignants je vais
rejoindre ce qu'a dit madame en partie
c'est à dire que en 2008 quand on est
passé à quatre jours les enseignants
l'ont très très mal vécu n'était pas du
tout d'accord
c'est vraiment le plus mauvais rythme
pour les pour les élèves donc et ça
c'est fait effectivement sans
concertation et c'est souvent ça le cas
et pour les enseignants c'est quelque
chose qui me laisse des traces 2008 donc
on impose des cas de shu 2012
forme peillon on passe à 4 jours et ni
les enseignants auraient pu accueillir
cette réforme plutôt favorablement
parce qu'effectivement elle elle permet
vraiment de retrouver un rythme meilleur
pour les enfants
la difficulté c'est que en tout cas pour
les enseignants pour les enfants c'était
une meilleure chose au niveau du rythme
même si on n'a pas tenu compte à ce
moment là il n'y a pas eu suffisamment
de concertation en tout cas au départ
lorsque cette réforme elle a été
demandée est mise en place par les
municipalités et en fait les enseignants
étaient on va pas dire la dernière roue
du carrosse mais en fait été obligé de
se enfin de se plier en fête avec eux
c'était la place très importante des
municipalités finalement dans tout à
fait alors en soi qui est de la
concertation etc
mais elle aurait pu avoir lieu en amont
voilà après ce qui est difficile c'est
que on sait que les rythmes des enfants
ils sont pas les mêmes pour les élèves
de maternelle ou pour des élèves
d'élémentaire et c'est cette réforme
elle a été mise en place sans tenir
compte de cette difficulté et les
enseignants aujourd'hui reconnaissent
bien qu'en maternelle enfin et depuis le
départ c'est très fort mais elle a été
très compliqué moi j'ai envie d'être un
peu provocateur on a entendu les enfants
sont fatigués avant les enfants était
fatigué il ya eu la réforme très vite
dans l'un des deux parents d'ira mais
avec cette réforme les enfants sont
encore plus fatigué il ya eu des
rapports qui ont dit il faut faire cette
réforme il ya des rapports qu'on dit
avec le dernier ministre
on peut arrêter cette réforme mais
monsieur blanc caire il ya eu une étude
semblerait qu'il y en a eu un de plus
qui qui qui est sérieux dans tout ça
quoi finalement
est ce que vous leur tour que vous avez
thierry falconnet ville de chenôve
vous invitez parce qu'on aime bien
parler avec vous mais aussi parce que la
commune de chenaux elle est emblématique
d'un certain nombre de difficultés que
peuvent avoir des enfants bien sûr qu
est-ce qui remontait pour vous cette
réforme elle fatigue ou cette réforme et
l'aide allait l'enfant sur cinq dont
parlait à belém rappeler d'abord que on
est la seule la seule commune de de
l'académie de dijon à voir arrêt plus
donc ça veut dire que l'état reconnaît
qu' effectivement sur le quartier
politique de la ville nous avons des
enfants qui sont qui accumule les
difficultés difficultés sociales
difficultés scolaires donc leur apporter
la meilleure offre de services et les
meilleures qualités
d'éducation d'apprentissage c'est pour
une collectivité comme la nôtre c'est
rétablir cette nécessaire égalité
république avec les moyens de l'internet
et avec les moyens de le faire parce que
là on n'a pas encore parlé de ça mais
les moyens quand on fait un choix
politique on met les moyens
c'est tout et aujourd'hui les nappes
coûte à la collectivité 114 mille euros
sur un une dépense globale d'environ
d'environ 350 mille euros donc
effectivement c'est un choix budgétaires
importants nous avons pris la décision
également de ne pas faire de ne pas
facturer les les activités péri
scolaires aux enfants et donc aux
familles parce que nous ne voulions pas
que cette cette réforme le passage de
quatre jours et demi et les nouvelles
activités périscolaires soit au
détriment des familles et que de fait en
les facturant nous puissions les et
quartier dansaert de macarthur a donc on
l'a fait on a fait ce choix là le retour
que nous avons aujourd'hui est un retour
très positif et je pense que c'est aussi
une des difficultés je veux pas plagier
l'actuel président de la république en
disant que c'est très difficile de
réformer en même temps mais en même
temps aujourd'hui les retours sont
plutôt positifs retour plutôt positif
quand on a en primaire quasiment 70 % de
participation des enfants on a mille six
cents enfants scolarisés primaires et
maternelles h aux noces on ne l'a
quasiment 1000 qui fréquentent les
activités périscolaires avec
effectivement un point que le comité de
pilotage que nous avons mis en place à
chaud pour voilà pour évaluer pour
ajuster un point qui reste compliquée
celle scellée maternelle alors justement
on vient sur facebook parce que
l'émission est diffusée en même temps
sur facebook de nous poser une question
qui est je me tourne vers vous et le
kazakh quelqu'un nous demandent à quand
elle est la distinction entre maternelle
et élémentaire est ce que c'est pas par
là de manière par cette différence qu'il
aurait fallu commencer
c'est vrai que c'est enfin c'est quelque
chose qui doit pouvoir être abordée
concertée et réfléchie
cette différence entre des enfants plus
jeunes et des enfants plus grands
maintenant je rejoins quand on veut une
réforme on se donne les moyens et et
cette réforme elle n'a pas un autre sens
était suffisamment aboutie et c'est
surtout que alors on se focalise
aujourd'hui sur 4 jours ou quatre jours
et demi
mais on ne parle pas en fait des
différences horaires sur la journée puis
s'il ya des communes qui ont pas
forcément réduit énormément la journée
on ne parle pas du rythme sur l'année
scolaire aussi c'est vrai que le nombre
de journées des enfants mais on peut
aussi travailler et nous enfin tout cas
les enseignants souhaiterait que soit
revu ce rythme sur l'année scolaire qui
est un rythme complètement dément on le
voit notre zone de vacances cette année
on va avoir quatre semaines entre les
vacances de noël et les vacances de
février on aura onze semaines en fin
d'année donc après on parle de la
fatigue des enfants du rythme d enfance
on aimerait bien que cette réforme soit
effectivement fait pour finir ça va nous
faire une autre édition les vacances
comment c'était chez vous didier migaud
est ce que en gros bas vous avez
appliqué les quatre jours et demi mais
que vous aviez pas grand chose à mettre
en terme de moyens et de capacité pour
que ce que chenot fait pour certains
enfants vous puissiez le faire à
brétigny en tout à fait nous n'avez pas
on avait pas de structure on en
discutait tout à l'heure on n'avait pas
de structures associatives suffisamment
robuste pour pouvoir effectivement
proposé aux aux enfants des activités
dans le cadre des nappes d'autant plus
qu' on n'a pas pu changer de nom plus
les horaires c'est que quand on était
contraint par les horaires du transport
scolaire
mais globalement les journées n'ont
absolument pas changé donc les enfants
ont eu
qui avaient des heures de classe avant
et après partait en bus ou en
périscolaire pour la garderie a
globalement continué à voir les
les cours puis après avec leur l'heure
où les trois quarts d'heure de nappes
après le périscolaire et bus exemple
journée oscilleront qu'ils avaient un
jour inalement pas d'effet en tout cas
chez vous aucun effet et puis après avec
le phénomène qui était évoqué les
maternelles qui était particulièrement
les enfants maternelle particulièrement
fatigué qu'il fallait réveiller après la
pause méridienne de leur sieste pour les
mettre aux nappes
globalement le respect du rythme de
l'enfant et vous vous avez essayé
non vraiment essayer puisque nous nous
n'avions que 70 enfants dans notre école
mais nous dépensions 20000 euros pour
nos nappes donc globalement on avait
décidé de ses moyens nous avons décidé
de trouver des gens pour faire les
activités notre programme d'éducation
était fait conjointement avec les
parents les enseignants et les élus donc
on a vraiment essayé de tout mettre
c'est d'ailleurs vous vous êtes mis à y
croire oui tout à fait c'est en fait
j'ai commencé à y croire j'ai mis tout
le monde autour de la table des gens qui
déjà était contre les parents et les
enseignants déjà été contre au moment où
on l'a mis en place en 2014 mais parce
que faisait le travail ensemble on a
réussi à le mettre en place
le problème des maternelles s'est
rapidement posé est donc un an après on
a changé et donc les maternelles qui
avait alors déjà on avait différencier
les maternelles des prises des
élémentaires ce que les élémentaires
avait deux fois dans la semaine une
heure et demie alors que les maternelles
c'était quatre fois trois quarts d'heure
qu'on avait mis en fin de matinée et
qu'on a ensuite changé à la demande de
l'institutrice et qu'on a mis en fin
d'après midi
enfin on enfin à 3 heures et les petits
s'il faisait la sieste faisait la sieste
il se réveillait y venait il faisait
alors chassé son bien moyennant quoi
tout le monde a voulu arrêter moyennant
quoi tout le monde a voulu arrêter parce
que je crois que le problème du mercredi
matin à est crucial et les parents se
plaignant est effectivement de cette
fatigue j'ai demandé si nous étions
vraiment volontaire et c'était pas nous
n'avions pas l'argent mais on allait
chercher ailleurs parce que je suis
d'accord quand on décide d'une politique
et notamment pour les enfants
on y met les moyens mais donc on a
demandé à ce que les parents d'élèves
face un sondage est à peu près 75 % des
parents ont répondu et à 90% ils ont
répondu qu'il fallait arrêter
donc il ya un moment en tant que élu je
suis quand même un peu obligé les
enseignants son compte chez nous les
parents sont contre donc je me suis
rallié à cet avis mais je crois que le
mercredi matin est un vrai sujet et les
vacances aussi je crois que si on
pouvait et allez un petit peu plus dans
d'autres pays
ça se fait ce mercredi matin c'était ça
le problème où c'était aussi ce qu'on
entend là c'est à dire en réalité dans
le monde rural
pas grand chose à mettre dans les nappes
mais c'est vous c'est votre rythme et
votre confort de vie mercredi matin
c'est celui des enfants
moi ça ne simplifie pas les choses de
passer à quatre jours il faut que je
retrouve une garde s'était pas simple
déjà avant parce qu'il finissait à 11
heures et qu'on avait qu'un moyen de
transport n'y avait pas de garde y avait
rien après mais c'est pas plus simple
aujourd'hui dont personnellement c'est
pas mon confort c'est vraiment que nous
on n'avait rien n'avait pas d'un appui
aérien mis en place
donc de toute manière et on c'était
difficile de mettre en place déjà par
les moyens puisque on est des petites
communes et on n'a pas les moyens et
d'autre part c'était compliqué à mettre
en place aussi par rapport aux
transports on n'avait pas transports
après les enfants se retrouver sans
moyen pour rentrer chez eux
puisqu'on est sur quatre communes donc
c'est vrai que c'est nous le retour en
arrière simplifie la vie des enfants qui
sont moins fatigués qui toute manière
les mythes choisissent leur activité
plutôt que des nappes qui seraient
imposées par l'école alors il avait
d'abord il ya ce à skis et ski a pas
aussi dans cette affaire le lobby entre
guillemets des clubs des associations
d'un système français qui était là prêt
existant et qui a été quand même
largement bousculé par ça c'est le
problème c'est pas par exemple dans le
monde rural on s'est souvent que les
adjoints au maire il s'occupe aussi du
club de foot s'occupe de plein de choses
c'est venu perturber des choses non
c'est pas ça lourd il perturbé tu vas
surnom est ce que est ce que l'intérêt
justement si quand on a ses forces vives
1 est-ce que c'est pas justement de
mettre ces gens là autour d'une table et
de passer d'une préoccupation d'une
décision d'une somme de choix
individuels à vrai choix collectifs
vous parliez d'élus effectivement quand
vous avez des retours mais je comprends
que c'est c'est terrible pour un maire
de poulx devoir elle est impressionnant
que cette histoire là je trouve
l'histoire saint sauveur elle est
impressionnant pour cent de parents qui
vous disent finalement on veut revenir
en arrière
bien évidemment que pour un élu c'est
une responsabilité énorme que d'essayer
d'aller contre sa mère ait pour autant
et pour autant c'est les avez les deux
camps même et pour autant est-ce qu'il
n'est pas dans notre responsabilité
d'élus de porter justement ces voix là
où ces voix de tous ces parents qui sont
que l'école a éloigné d'eux éloigné
d'elle et qui ont besoin qu'on soit
précis et qu'on soit on le ramène les
éléments pour décider qu'on leur dise
voilà ce qu'il faut pour vos enfants ce
qu'il faut pour nos enfants
si ça que c'est compliqué parce que ce
qu'il faut pour vos enfants les gens
l'ont entendu trois fois en dix ans de
façon différente avec chaque fois un
argumentaire ai vu qu'une réforme
j'ai vu que celle de 2013 qui pour la
première fois mettait l'enfant au centre
de la préoccupation et qui avant on n'a
rien 2008 y avait pas d'arguments
pédagogique là moi c'est la première
fois qu'ils avaient des arguments
rapport éducation nationale de la dette
qui dit qui dit quoi qui dit que là on
n'a même pas pris le temps d'évaluer set
avant de voir s'il fallait tout cas
c'est revenir sains alors c'est quoi
c'est une mauvaise réforme tarifaire
connaissent enfin je veux dire non mais
une réforme parce que par exemple vous
parliez des transports scolaires on a
beaucoup dit c'est une réforme qui était
vu de paris de façon générale et qui
prenait pas en compte la réalité de la
décentralisation en france des strates
administratives du fonctionnement du
monde du monde rural mauvaise mauvaise
réforme une réforme faite pour les
villes je vais te même provocateur
réforme pensé par des élus socialistes
pour les maires des grandes villes
socialistes qu'ils étaient
majoritairement l'époque dense et ce
sera ma mon petit clin d'oeil politique
de l'émission
donc moi je ça a été dit il ça a été dit
et un moment écoutez toutes les études
là je veux faire un petit pas de côté
toutes les études disent aujourd'hui que
la la semaine scolaire d'aider des
enfants français comme ça a été dit tout
à l'heure était trop chargée sur quatre
jours qu'on avait les les jours d'école
les mois les moins importants de toute
l'europe occidentale et ensuite on a les
résultats des études pisa qui sortent de
l'ordinaire
quand même la france est mal placée mais
je pense qu'à un moment donné du coup on
essaye quelque chose on essaie quelque
chose c'était une une réforme qui a été
très largement concertée au départ avec
avec les associations de parents
d'élèves les fédérations de parents
d'élèves national il ya une conférence
nationale dans nos collectivités
nous avons tous je crois mis en place
des comités de pilotage qui associe tous
les acteurs de l'école et puis je pense
qu'à un moment donné il faut aussi ne
pas confondre ce qui est de l'intérêt
des enfants et de l'intérêt des parents
on sait très bien
on sait très bien par exemple que le
samedi matin pose de gros problèmes aux
familles recomposées
mais ça c'est des histoires d'adultes
c'est pas des histoires dans ça peut
devenir des histoires d'enfance et vous
avez le temps des difficultés mais le
papa ou la maman qui viennent une
semaine sur deux rencontres et les
les professeurs d'école à la sortie de
l'école le samedi matin c'est pas
forcément déplaisant effectivement ça
fait un week-end un week-end - moins
long moins important mais c'est aussi
une relation avec avec avec l'école j'en
déduis que ça pourrait être la piste le
retour à quatre jours et demi mais elle
samedi matin où j'ai terminé je souhaite
faire une concertation
à chaud parce que parce que chez nous
devons continuer cette année pour que
cette année il ya quand même des des
incertitudes quand par exemple on nous
dit que le fonds de concours de l'état
peut disparaître en 2019
même si à la volonté politique et des
contraintes budgétaires aussi et et le
dossier des intervenants on nous en a
parlé sur facebook
beaucoup de gens se posaient la question
tous les gens qui pourront trouver du
travail de cette manière là à chenôve
nous avons 20 contractuels 20
contractuels non permanents qui
participent aux activités périscolaires
ça peut faire trente mille emplois
touchés en france
donc c'était une réforme qui était bonne
pour l'emploi aussi et qui a permis de
professionnaliser un certain de nos
personnels
donc il y aura une concertation à chaud
sur sur cette question mais moi je
souhaite qu'on embrasse toutes les
données du problème c'est à dire qu'on
évoque effectivement les quatre jours et
demi
je pense que nous reparlerons du samedi
matin c'est à dire que ça sera un choix
qui sera proposé aux parents et puis moi
je souhaite aussi que tous les parents
d'élèves soient consultés pas seulement
les parents qui siègent dans les
conseils d'école mais que tous les
parents qui ont un enfant scolarisé à
chenôve s'exprime sur cette question
mais s'exprime sur la globalité en
sachant et je l'avais déjà dit moi je
suis plutôt favorable à ce que nous
restions à quatre jours et demi parce
que c'était une bonne réforme
la question du mercredi matin faudra
qu'abandonner on parle du travail des
femmes les carrières des femmes parce
que qu'ils assument généralement les
enfants le mercredi c'est rarement les
messieurs et les femmes mettent leur
carrière entre parenthèses pour pouvoir
s'occuper des enfants et on se rend
compte là ce sont des chasseurs des
études je sois des études c'est si mal
c'est le fait que c'est plus facile de
faire garder toute la journée le
mercredi que de faire garder que le
mercredi après-midi et ses jours du coup
mon contraire le vendredi matin amis
difficultés certaines femmes on se rend
compte depuis deux ans que des femmes
ont repris une carrière professionnelle
plus dynamique
parce que effectivement elles peuvent
assumer des responsabilités jusqu'au
faisait rire elle connaît pas ce qu'il
nous reste trois minutes d'émission moi
j'ai une question à vous poser à tous
est-ce que la situation actuelle n'est
pas une situation un peu inégalitaire et
est ce qu'elle est pas un peu
inquiétante entre des écoles à quatre
jours dans le monde rural sans aucune
activité aujourd'hui si les parents
n'ont pas les moyens de le payer
des communes comme chevaux enfin
l'exemple de dijon par exemple qui gars
qui maintient sa je pense le point de
vue la fcpe saisie d'inquiétude
là-dessus ça l'est du point de vue d'un
fcpe on a juste une instance où tout cas
décidé d'abandonner le cinquième enfant
est partout sur les territoires faut pas
oublier je le disais tout à l'heure
quand on nous discutions entre nous que
60% des enfants qui sont en difficultés
ne sont pas en réseau d'éducation
prioritaire
voilà ses enfants en difficulté y en à
partir à néant alors dans les communes
et les nouveaux rythmes ils sont bons
pour six enfants en difficulté mais ils
sont bons pour tous les enfants
sauf que ceux qui vont bien s'en sortent
toujours c'est ce que disent c'est ce
que disent certains ça vous inquiète
cette situation inégalitaire finalement
vous avez obtenu les quatre jours mais
ça compense pas la différence par
rapport à d'autres enfants
nous on a très peu de cas dans notre
dans nos communes on a des enfants en
difficulté et justement il profite du
mercredi pour aller dans des centres
spécialisés voir des orthophonistes et
les parents ça leur libère un peu enfin
ils ont libéré un peu tant pour les
enfants pour pouvoir s'occuper justement
de ces cas spécifiques
c'est vrai que c'est dangereux
d'inégalité vous acquiescez ah ça oui
j'acquiesce tout à fait je pense que
l'essai sans concertation ont laissé
chaque commune chaque face à la
situation
chacun fait un peu comme il l'entend
avec je pense quand même un élément qui
nous rejoint tout c'est quand même une
volonté de se couper de l'enfant et de
trouver des solutions pour que l'école
soit effectivement reprenne son rôle de
quel est son rôle
effectivement républicain de donner sa
chance à chacun après c'est ça nécessite
de la concertation de la discussion pour
qu'effectivement tous les acteurs
arrivent à se mettre d'accord sur un
rythme qui va convenir à l'enfant et
puis aux contraintes sociétales que l'on
a aujourd'hui un petit mot des
enseignants le gars qui a quand même
cette inégalité ils la ressentent les
enseignants forcément les enseignants la
ressentez la crédit et c'est vrai que ça
c'est pas de septembre c'est à dire
qu'on ne peut pas continuer avec ledit
système différent il faut qu'il ya
effectivement face à la demande des
enseignants et qui a une harmonisation
sur le territoire et que tous les
enfants et tous les élèves puissent être
traités de la même manière et avec les
moyens qu'il faut c'est à dire que les
difficultés que peuvent rencontrer
certaines communes il faut que l'état
prenne ses responsabilités elise aide ça
c'est vraiment une demande forte et et
j'en profite pour vous couper parce que
c'est la fin de notre émission et vous
me regardez on en aurait il passé la
matinée merci à tous les 6 5 samedi
prochain nous retournons dimanche
prochain nous retourne en studio pour un
autre numéro dimanche en politique vous
dimanche en bois